It's always fun to have you.
I'm pumped.
Maury, I met Maury 10 years ago.
I went to his show.
And you met him.
Well, yeah, I have a picture
with him,
I was trying to look
for it on my Instagram
but I can't find it.
Oh yeah.
He's a nice guy.
I say Maury Povich,
what's the right way to say-
Povich.
Povich, okay.
Sometimes I say Paw-vich.
I think you said
Pavich in the hall.
Pavich. Which is the right way?
We'll ask him. I feel like
he's a guy you can ask,
"How do you say your name
that we should all this?"
And I feel like you
could just go with, Maury,
and everybody knows who it is.
There's no other Maury.
"Tuesdays With-"
Right, "Tuesdays with Maury."
Yeah, I read that book
and got something from it.
Same, samesies.
I was like, "Oh, I'm going
to start forgiving everyone."
Yeah. When I was in
physical therapy school,
we had to learn about ALS
and I couldn't study
and focus on it.
So I just was like, "I'll read
Tuesdays with Morrie."
'Cause he had ALS.
Oh yeah.
And I failed. You had to know-
You had to know-
I mean it's a graduate program.
I was like, "I'm just going
to read this novel."
Maury Povich is in the studio,
everyone,
I told you
he was gonna drop by.
It was gonna happen quick.
We're ready.
Nice to see you.
What's up, brother,
how you doing?
That's Chris, this is Andrew.
I'm Nikki.
Hi, how are you, Maury.
Nice to meet you.
Good to see you.
So many people-
No.
Seven people.
Everybody.
Everyone's so excited about you
when I talk about you.
People glow, they have a story,
they have a relationship
with you.
I learned last night
from doing some research,
that you were
the "A Current Affair" guy.
Of course, yeah.
Of course, but I was a child
when that show was on
so I didn't-
You actually watched it?
Yes, my mom watched it
and I loved it.
It gave me an appreciation
for really, good journalism.
Do you remember the sound?
Yes.
Ka-chung.
Yes, ka-chung,
I remember all of it.
But I forgot that that was you
and then you became
Maury Povich.
It's just ...
No.
Making the connection,
I loved that show.
That show.
First of all the ka-chung,
the sound, came from ...
We always said
when we started the show,
we wanted to have something
like the "60 Minutes" clock,
so that if you heard it,
"Oh, it's on."
And you would watch.
They put the old time
elementary school
construction paper cutters,
the sound of
a construction paper cutter.
Put with the swish
of a golf club.
Put through a synthesizer
and that was named
after my wife, the "ka-chung."
It's so good.
Yeah, it used to scare me.
Those are all such satisfying
sounds layered
on top of each other.
I know.
It makes sense why it worked.
This is like '86, so it was
the first days of synthesizing.
That's what they used.
Oh and it worked.
I remember it, it still ...
Yeah, that was always
something my mom had on.
But now, Maury-
Your mom still has
my show on now.
Exactly, oh my gosh,
everyone has your show on.
I mean, in this room,
Noa, both my producer
and Chris Destefano,
have you been
to a live taping, Andrew?
I have not but I'm going
tomorrow.
Where have you all been?
I've been, I've been.
They have been to live tapings-
Yeah, I was there 10 years ago.
It was awesome.
I got a picture with you too.
It's wild, it's crazy.
It's really-
This is the tourist thing to do
when you come to New York City.
I'm telling you, the live taping
of my show
is as good entertainment
as you would ever want.
My live audience
makes the show.
I mean, it's the heartbeat
of the show.
'Cause they go crazy.
And they all think they know
who the father is.
In my episode, when we found out
it was the father,
we went out of our minds.
It was like the touchdown.
Because before, we like,
"There's no way he's the father,
there's no way ..."
And then when he was,
we were like, "Wooo."
Chris you were saying in line
there was shit talking.
In line there were people,
in the episode that I was at,
the family of one of the guys
on the show and they were like,
"I know he's the father,
I know he's the father!"
And then people were like,
you know nobody knows anything,
I was with my friends
who were like,
"No, he's not. No he's not."
We have no frame of reference.
Then when he was,
we were just like, "Whoa!"
And they were like,
"I told you." It was great.
Vivid memories,
these people are conjuring
just from being at your show
10 years ago.
It truly sounds like such
a great life experience to have.
I heard a story of a NFL
quarterback,
this is many years ago,
said that, the players would be
in the locker room
and they would not
go out to practice
until they found out
who the father was.
Losing games.
Shaquille O'Neal watches my show
every single day and Shaq,
and what he does is
he calls up all his friends
and they bet on
who the father is.
Oh my god.
Great, great, I love it.
So fun. And Noa, I wanted to
give you a second to tell Maury
what he means to you.
What?
'Cause you went to a taping.
Yeah. Took a T.V. production
class in high school,
this is 15 years ago.
And I went to a live
taping of your show
and that's when I knew that
I had to work in production.
I was watching
your stage manager
and I was just mesmerized,
like,
"What is that job? I want to do
something like that."
Really?
Yeah.
And that's when you got
the itch.
Yeah and from then on I knew
I had to work behind the scenes.
So you've been in production
ever since?
Yeah.
Isn't that cool?
Do you produce this show?
-Yes.
-Yeah.
How's it going?
Amazing, it's the
best time of my life.
It's so fun. How do ...
I'm guessing people are having
fun working on your show.
How have you-
Well, the most amazing part
about that is that my producers,
my associate producers,
my cameramen,
have been there
for 15, 20 years.
People like the atmosphere,
the way we work,
the work environment.
The first talk show I did
was for Paramount
and that was 28 years ago.
And I still have five people
throughout my staff
who've been with me
28 years.
Wow. That is impressive.
As they say, you sent my kids
through school,
now they've got kids.
I mean, now those kids
are ready to go to school.
I mean, but it starts
at the top.
I mean, people who ...
It starts with you and that
just is a credit to you.
And the people
that you attract.
Look, this business is ...
I mean, I've seen so much
in the television,
radio business in my life that,
it's easy to pick out the fools.
The a-holes show themselves
very early
and so therefore, you know
exactly what to guard against.
Yeah.
So that's how I do it.
And as far as the suits,
the executives,
there's nothing better
to keep distance
between you and suits
than a good rating.
If you get a good rating,
they don't care about you.
You'll never hear from them.
You're never gonna know,
they're your best friend.
Oh yeah, oh yeah.
The second the ratings
dip.
The moment there's a dip,
"Well, we think
that you oughta do this."
Really?
Where the hell have you been?
Yes, oh yeah,
who am I speaking to even?
I wanted to ask you about
the daily grind of doing a show.
I mean, how many episodes
are we talking, 4,000?
How many have you done?
-Oh gosh.
-Of the show?
Between 3 and 4,000, I think.
Yeah, insane.
It's amazing.
So how many do you tape a week?
We tape five a week.
I tape usually ...
We tape in Stamford,
Connecticut and we tape three on
Thursdays and two on Fridays.
We work about,
I don't know, 27 weeks a year.
Do 100 and I don't know,
30 or 40 shows.
Do you ever reach a point
where you're like,
Okay, I get ...
How do you muster the,
'cause you never
seem bored of it.
How do you muster the-
Because I believe ...
Even though for instance,
between the lie detector themes
and the DNA themes, those are
our two signature themes.
But since I came out of news,
for many, many years,
I've always believed
in storytelling
and I just want to find
even with those two themes
all the time, unique qualities
of every single story.
And so I believe each person,
each personality has
a unique quality about them,
either good or bad,
that I can bring out.
And if I continue to do that,
I won't get bored.
So that's my mantra.
That's really cool.
And you can tell that,
that's why we love the show,
you bring out characters.
And the other thing is,
and I've always said
this about talk shows,
and I learned this a long
time ago when I first started.
It's like being in a campaign,
to be elected.
You have to knock
on somebody's door,
they have to open the door,
they have to welcome you in.
They have to feel
so comfortable with you
that they'll sit you
at the table
or sit you on the couch.
And you have to become
a member of that family.
And if you can do that,
then you got a chance
at being successful.
That's the way I've looked at it
all my life
and I've looked on it as being
an advocate for the audience.
For instance, I don't know,
I've never known
the result of any DNA test
or lie detector test
before I open up the envelope.
'Cause you're an advocate
for the audience.
You're representing
their experience.
Right and I don't want to know
anything more than they do.
'Cause if I did, then I'd skew
the questions in a certain way.
That's fascinating because
I've hosted two shows,
two talk shows that didn't
last past two seasons.
And I did feel that the audience
just didn't get to know me
or didn't trust me.
There was some element of that
or wasn't given a chance to ...
whatever it was.
But you're really tapping
into something as a host,
trying to approach the job
like you're their advocate.
No question.
It's a really cool approach and
it makes sense why it's worked.
And yet you can bring out
your own vulnerabilities.
Yes.
You bring out
you're own experiences.
I mean, for instance, I mean,
I can't tell you how many times
I've told various fathers
for instance,
who are raising a child
that is not theirs.
And whether they will continue
to raise that child,
I keep saying,
"Look, my wife and I
have a child in our family.
I'm not the birth father
of that child.
And he is as close to me
as my birth children.
There's no difference."
So you have to be able
to unload yourself.
Yes.
To the guests and the viewers.
That is extremely compassionate
and it makes them ...
That's great that you share
that experience.
And another thing is that ...
Look, there is nothing
in my life that comes close
to the experiences
that my guests go through.
I never lived those experiences.
But there's some connective-
There's a bridge.
... Human instinct.
That they feel safe
in my company or on my show.
I feel safe right now.
They don't feel judged.
-Yeah, I do too.
-You do?
I feel completely safe
right now.
You give that air of a like
a therapist.
I don't feel-
But I'm not a therapist.
I mean...
No but you're therapeutic.
Just that voice,
I don't know what it is.
Very soothing voice, yeah.
I just feel so good right now.
Do you know how much whiskey
and cigarettes?
That's what I like.
You're drunk for sure.
But man, I just feel good,
my blood pressure's
low right now.
I know.
Really? How can you tell?
I'm not sweating,
my heart's not palpate,
I don't feel like
I'm gonna pass out.
I just feel calm. I'm gonna
get somebody pregnant tonight.
I'm just gonna do it,
I'm coming on your show.
Cool.
That's the only way ...
Yeah, all right, great.
See you in about six months.